- you know one thing we really wanted to
know from you is how often did you have
to fight for your next directing job you
know cuz when you look at your credits I
believe it's 49 directing credits and it
almost seems to come seamlessly you know
and some of these filmmakers that I know
that I'm around it's like that next
project is such a big fight and it
almost appears on your on your side of
things that project that the project has
been lined up so I just love to hear
about them from you how often did you
have to fight for the next film it's
always a fight David it's always a fight
it never comes easy the lucky thing
about me was that I worked was able I
was interested in the theater so in the
60s I would I worked but did three or
four plays I did a play by Doris Lessing
who won the Nobel Prize for for
literature and I I did musical with
Lionel Bart called Maggie Mae in the
West End it ran for two years in the
West End so I was always so if I got
stuck let's go you know and films are
expensive things they're not easily
given I mean you think someone's gonna
give you - okay alright David here's 25
million dollars come back with the film
think about it so you did I feel always
feel a tremendous responsibility and
people give me huge sums of money and
I've got to do something that's
hopefully will make some of the money
back but it's gotten more and more
difficult different I know that's a
brother that's a function of my age or
whether I think it's a net but I know I
know it's not my age because I know a
lot of directors and a lot of writers I
know a lot of producers is tempo and
they're all making the same complaint
ever since the recession the banks are
not lending their money filmmaking is
based on banks lending you money people
think you know Warner Brothers has all
the money when they when they make it
don't know the bore of the money they
haven't they have the collateral they
have their their libraries this
collateral it's true but independent
filmmaking
you get some money here I get some money
from the Canadian government is on the
Canadian
I get money from Spain and Italy injure
me from distributors in there and slowly
get a little money together so it's a
long torturous process but look at the
situation in Europe they get Spain has
no money Italy has no money I'm working
on an Italian film Franco NATO right now
and they're having trouble the Italians
have a very good state subsidy for films
that are made that are shot in Italy
that they have no money so it's very
difficult right now a lot of independent
producers and directors are complaining
bitterly it's but it's but it's all good
it's just it's all a matter of degree it
was always difficult but now it's more
difficult it wasn't the past and and
reflecting back and all the films you
have made which like sort of which film
would you say was the the hardest and
the most challenging to get off the
ground
hmm they're all have their like you know
one of my most successful films was was
um first blood the first Rambo film
right yeah now I believe in that film I
thought oh this is a winner I loved it
because again there's an action picture
the story was told
totally pictorially and one point we
were we were gonna have Rambo never say
a word because Sylvester Stallone and I
worked on the script together and and
after a while I said no that's not gonna
work
slide the he would say something here
and what it looks like you're
artificially trying to create a
situation but they had a very salubrious
effect on descriptives very full of
pictures in action and very little
dialogue but I see the head of Warner
Brothers asked me to work on it and that
works on that word the script then that
was before Sylvester was involved and
the after six months I worked on the
script they say you know we're not gonna
make this film I said what I said why
I've been working on for six months why
if you're making it you had 16 months of
my life bit poured into the script and
he said we think that the Americans
don't want to hear about the Vietnam War
American ancestor
and I said well you could have thought
of that six months ago and I was really
depressed deep enough so a year goes by
and to producers to new young producers
had a small company called Kuroko and
Mario Kassar was one of them and he and
Auntie Vanya was the other one and
became friends and they said to me
Tibbits you really can make a film for
us I said looking to make films yeah he
got me scripts I said yeah it's a great
script over Warner Brothers but you'll
never get it I said wise and I said this
year because don't like handing out
scripts like that that they possess
because suppose it's supposing it's a
success they looked like idiots for
giving it away
so I said that it's very hard to get
material out of it the distributors they
said well tell us what it is so I told
mine something sounds interesting
it took him a full year of negotiations
and they finally gave the script a lot
of it had to do with the fact it was
very power one of my best friend's was
in a power position to company I don't
want to embarrass him but the main his
name but he helped me together because
he knew much what I cared about it so
there it is that film took two years to
three years and finally we got it and
ever and no other film that not that we
had the possession of no other film had
this experience which I had with that
one they said who do you want to play
the part said Andy and Mary oh and I
said I want Sylvester Stallone and they
said are you sure and I said yeah I said
well you know he's his reputation
there's a bit right now we have several
flops after rocky
a fist and etc and I said no he'd be
perfect this part I know I want him
so we phoned him up on a Tuesday night
seven escape from Wednesday morning he
said yes usually takes like six months
for the first star to say yes yes I
can't believe this one 12 hours I get a
response so so for all the difficulties
suddenly the most difficult part usually
that came easy
you